another show coming to town the harlem
globetrotters are spreading game and
love to vegas and did you know
their showman scooter christensen is
from our city nice shout out he stopped
by earlier this week to tell us how you
can check out their tricks on tour
welcome scooter thanks for having me how
are you doing i'm good
you're carrying basketball i'm jealous
because i outcome yeah i sleep with this
thing i know you do i know you do
so let's start first and foremost you
know this organization is more than just
basketball that's right it's black
history it's black excellence just kind
of introduce people who don't know even
though that just isn't possible yeah
well i always tell people if you've ever
been to if you've never been to a
globetrotter game it's not your average
basketball game you know we have we
entertain people we do a great job of
mixing basketball and entertainment at
the same time and i always tell people
don't worry about the score because
we're going to win don't worry about the
score but but we're seeing a little
sneak peek right now yeah but but we
make people smile we make people have
fun you know we've been down the last
couple years with the whole culvert yeah
of course uh pandemic being quarantined
but now we're off and running and we're
dedicating this tour spread game tour to
curly neal as today is 2 22
22.
his number was 22 and he uh played for
22 years so yeah i mean it is beyond
alignment right there there it is right
and i have to say i get to add to that
alignment because i wore 22.
in college look at you i know
so you mentioned the spread the spread
game tour so let's talk about that what
can we expect well you're going to have
your uh we still got the four point shot
which is 30 feet away from the rim you
know steph curry range and beyond we got
crazy crossovers we got dynamic dunks
we've added a lot of uh new characters
to the game this year uh i want to give
it away but also also uh people are used
to the uh to the blue and red white
striped shorts it's all black black uh
bbc we still got the red white blue here
but it's the black it's the black jersey
so um yeah it's it's we're excited man
it's so happy a little new something a
little new yeah okay and and speaking of
jerseys and merch um on february 26th
you guys are dropping a line a new line
right at lids
yeah yeah we are we just yeah so yeah so
we we're doing a whole bunch of stuff
this year so and it's just it's like you
said it's black excellence it's you know
it's it's it's the curly nail it's the
spread game we spread love and we
bringing smiles we doing what we do best
is bring smiles to families absolutely
right and let's talk a little bit more
about curly neil yes why are we
celebrating him in particular because
besides the tutu he's he's an icon i
mean when people think of hangul
charters the first person they think is
curly nail and they think of men like
them too but curly neal we're giving it
we're giving him his flowers and then uh
you know he's the epitome look at that i
mean look i mean i think i'm the only
one on the team that's still rocking the
ball ahead right now so
so i'm loving it though but i mean i had
the opportunity and was very blessed to
to meet with him and talk to him
one-on-one and just kind of pick his
brain you know and uh and i was so lucky
to do that and for him to for us to be
dedicate this tour to him is is it means
so much to us wonderful okay so march
1st here in vegas that's right speaking
of curly let's get to it i'm putting my
i'm putting this down okay i mean we
can't have you up here without
we have the music you have the music
going so you want to go into a pass you
want to spin which one okay i'm
so around the back between the legs hold
it out
right there you see that
somewhere dude
i can't give you a just a glow try to
pass now okay
around the back okay between the legs
okay hold it like this off the elbow and
then point it right as you do that all
right okay so around the back between
the legs
hold it out elbow
see
that's that's the spike you got to point
it right there just like this
all right next one next one hold your
finger just like that hold it super
tight this is the clasp you have to turn
your strong finger alright strong finger
here we go okay in three
two one don't move whatever you do don't
move hold still hold
[Music]
thank you okay that's just a sneak peek
of the actual show okay so harlem
globetrotters spread game tour march 1st
7 p.m at the thomas and max center for
more information just head to
thomasonmax.com
you're good